[Music]
hey every damn day the holiday season is
upon us that means spending time with
family which in my case means it's time
to drink and nobody knows more about
drinking than the good folks at
reno911.com when one clip show you can
watch full episodes right now in comedy
central.com it premiered 25 years ago
watch this clip oh hell yeah
well I'm great I'm doing ok I'm not so
good because you were weaving all over
the road there well can one thing
straight okay with the left hand I need
you to recite the alphabet from Z to a
backwards as fast as you can yeah sure
[Music]
z y x WV u TS r q p o NM l KJ IH g f e d
c b a remarkable i've actually never
seen anybody do that
oh my Blair so I'm I'm not worried about
your bladder right now
sure
right all right well you've got a pretty
good balance thank you I want you to
step bump step bump-bump step bump step
bump-bump five six seven hey step bump
step bump-bump step bump step bump-bump
pas de Bouree kick ball change step clap
five six seven eight you know what would
be good is if you hit kicked and then
you kind of did that and then a barrel
turn and then ha you know that was good
me that's really good you a dancer no no
no no not I'm just drunk was the time
that you guys were so obviously caught
doing something wrong but you tried to
maintain your innocence anyway in high
school my parents left town and I threw
a party very big for me classic
highschool boys' classic high school bad
boy it was very fun and then everyone
left and so I made sure to clean like
the entire house I got all the bottle
caps like I remember I found one under
the coffee table and I was like this is
gonna get me and then my parents get
home and they open the fridge and there
is a giant empty cardboard box of beer
[Music]
but I had never been bad ever so my
parents didn't know what to do and so we
just sat down like I was like don't do
that again let's watch our next clip
three times three times I'm sorry come
on
jail time no no no we're gonna don't
okay putting these in here Maisie you're
not wearing any pants now you ones you
want how about these these are good I
don't want to wear those stupid skirt
panties wait a second this is I'm back
you guys ever been arrested
I have not been arrested Gobbo she went
behind the bar and started throwing
t-shirts like she was a t-shirt gun just
like toss him and then she got thrown in
the cop car so we get we like pile their
money together and just like gave it the
guy was like okay but they were laughing
the whole time they were just like you
but that is literally only good that
time so then you piled your money
together to pay the cops like right yeah
Wow bad boys on this yeah I was once
voluntarily detained in college what
does that mean well so the cops caught
me for smoking pot and and then I lay in
this way I know and then I was so high
they were like do you need to go down to
the station and stay overnight and my
friends were like no he's fine no he's
fine and I was so freaked out because I
was like oh no I'm in trouble and I'm
high and I was like yeah I should I
should go and they just drove me down
and the guy was like okay so you can
speak to a psychiatrist on the phone if
you want and I was like okay I'm gonna
do that like I think I was such an idiot
and and so I did speak to a psychiatrist
on the phone and it was like 4:00 in the
morning you lose
you need to learn to deny to die I words
to live by
tonight city die Jordan tonight today
guy okay Bravo thank you so much for
coming so here's what I want to make
sure y'all understand right now right
off the top I called you to report a
crime and I don't have nothing to do
with okay oh this is a first I'm not
involved in the crime
I didn't perpetrate the crime I didn't
do anything okay I was yes ma'am yes we
can I was madam oh I was walking down
the street ok and I was indeed I'm not
gonna lie I'm a vagabond a bit I'm a
little bit of a bag about I was looking
for shelter I found this vehicle the
window was open and I climbed it I
looked in the trunk and there's
something in the trunk that I think may
be of interest to you so I made sure
that I called immediately what's a head
there's a head in the trunk
there's a head 23 year-old male head
okay okay then what would the
repercussions be hypothetically I hate
you Jerome
why did you we're not real playing
anymore playing real-life why'd you say
Jerome that's my cousin's name had just
come to me right now is your cousin
living area yeah he's alive with the
Lord alive with the Lord
I've never session anyone nor have I had
anyone snitch on me but there was a time
when I should like my best friend still
but we were like seven or eight and we
were at this camp and so it was a Jewish
camp and
so we were reading from the Torah yeah
and I thought it was dumb so instead of
reading I would just go like and it made
her laugh so hard and and she got in big
trouble for laughing dirty you're the
one who I called you to report a crime
and I don't have nothing to do with okay
Jay sure that's quick it's always sad
when someone dies huh this young man was
driving drunk comma without knowing how
to do it properly okay let me say that
again this young man was driving drunk
without having practiced so he would
know how to do it right now you're not
stupid and I'm not gonna treat you like
you are I'm gonna tell you something
that's pretty controversial some people
drive better when they're intoxicated
than they do when they're sober hi my
name is deputy Johnson I'm able to do
such a thing
all right think about it my day to day
life when I'm driving what am i doing
I'm playing air guitar maybe I'm trying
to wipe mustard off my pants or I'm
texting somebody but I'm sure as hell
not looking at the road yes I said hell
live with it when I am driving drunk 2
o'clock 10 o'clock Mirror Mirror every
30 seconds the air conditioners on me
I've got some speed metal on the radio
I'm pumped I'm paying attention believe
me I've been doing this since I was 11
years old I'm very good at it it's like
using condoms
or popping up penicillin before you have
multiple encounters you know safety yeah
see a lot of pretty girls here today a
lot of pretty girls some of you have
definitely got careers in gentlemen's
magazines later on an adult entertaining
all right I hope that when it comes time
to list your turn-offs that vehicular
manslaughter will be one of those
turn-off
all right what's a controversial opinion
that you guys have you mean like driving
drunk for example that some people are
better when they drive drunk rather than
drive sober well I feel like Natasha
yours you think all drugs and
prostitution should be legal and that's
what I wrote because I'm one judgment I
have of Natasha I'm like really
I traveled home to Boston this weekend
and I had to bring my mushrooms and and
I was at the Amtrak station and I was at
the Amtrak station and I saw that they
had like dogs and police officers there
and there was big signs like wheel
search your baggage and stuff and I was
getting nervous nervous and I was like
okay this is annoying that I have to be
nervous like I should be allowed to
carry pusher that's like this is crazy
anyway that's that I share that opinion
I believe yeah I just think like if
everything was legal I'd be like okay I
need these I push boundaries but I
really would do heroin if it was legal I
mean no I don't think so but I don't
know if it wasn't a vending machine
there are some days gonna be like yeah
I'll give it a shot yeah why the
response jarda you guys shut up words
yes I do
cheeri mike says man I wish Hannah would
come to my Thanksgiving and take all the
tension off me
so I could sneak out and get stoned and
fall asleep in the garage that's a
comment on Hannah's attention hacks
video for Thanksgiving and I also have a
Thanksgiving a video that I made over
the weekend friends giving vlogs so
watch that right now what's up guys
today is a very special day because
today is friendsgiving
and i'm about to invite all of my
childhood friends here a lot of friends
from middle school and high school I
happen to be living at home at the
moment so it's the perfect area to have
a friends giving my my mancave you can
see you
sort of like a bed area slash gymnasium
it's heavy I've invited in Michael Bay's
naughty Eric DeLong amber janela inna
and whoever shows up shows up pulls out
the old yearbook just in case anyone
wants to flip through but I invited most
of these people Michaela Justin Danielle
Casey Kelly Veronica the gang is
reuniting to be honest I really need
this to work out this is gonna be like a
potluck situation so I'm providing the
beer I think Eric along is bringing the
turkey he's a chef Christine is bringing
the mac and cheese caroline makes the
best cider john anthony
lindsay so far no one has responded to
the facebook event but that's totally
cool no one uses facebook anymore
whoever shows up shows up see where
people are at yo Joe what's up man it's
Jordan its Jordan just checking in if
you're coming by for friendsgiving it's
like 20 minutes past when friends get me
should start and no one's here hey
Jordan jo r da ni I think the
reception's bad my old friend friends
giving us back on so hey oh it's friends
giving not girlfriends giving so next
time just just let me know if some of
the Audrina bring someone cool let's uh
let's get started
[Music]
no she's throwing the vibe of the party
I think people are coming in like a sec
so yeah we've got a lot of other see you
later man good seeing you thanks for
having us and all right bye
friendsgiving do you guys have friends
yeah yeah I saw some friends when I was
back home in Colorado this week that's
cool Travis Macy if you're watching
thanks so much you have a beautiful
family what are your friends names
surely there's so many how's everyone in
the comments
you are our friends and we giving you
thanks
[Music]